ça a été on peut dire une grosse semaine
dans cette campagne électorale avec moi
vous la connaissez chantal hébert alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir on va
rapidement revenir sur ce débat d'hier
parce qu'un événement important dans
cette campagne c'est une évidence on a
préparé un tout petit pot pourri on
écoute ce qu'on vient tout de suite
il n'y a pas eu de 10 messieurs bruno
vous le savez très bien il n'y a pas eu
dit pourquoi parce qu'un oeil comme si
on enquête sur l'industrie de la
construction et si la ftq avait voulu
faire des pressions sur moi ne cherche
que nous l'a dit sous serment quand j'ai
rencontré madame marois je rencontrais
un mur un mur de béton je peux vous
l'assurer que vous avez eu la
responsabilité de deux grandes
organisations
le 15e et le chum et d'un coeur du cuse
homme vous aviez une association avec le
dock avec monsieur porte ou alors vous
pouvez pas donner
mon seul hymne à la population que vous
n'avez aucun scrupule sur ces questions
madame marois a mené de me lancer une
accusation par association à l'avenir
toutes les nominations importants vont
passer devant une commission
parlementaire vous êtes vous êtes prêts
à le voir mais vous l'avez pas fait
pendant 18 mois puis vous avez une amie
40 ou 50 personnes qui sait des copains
à damas au taux séparés comme la partie
divers
arguments pas d'âme en nommer des gens
compétents qui ont donné des résultats
qu il faudrait que les travailleurs
entre eux sur une chaîne de montage par
l'anglais pour vous m'expliquer à ces
intrus madame david olivier fils
emmanuel j'espère qu'ils sont en france
et il vient clients voir l'appareil qui
vont exporter j'espère aux états unis où
on en est ce client revient sur le
plancher du z lui veut parler aux
travailleurs et veut parler aux
contremaîtres commencé fait casciari si
j'étais le problème bien sûr les gens se
parlent français entre eux au travail
mais la connaissance et la connaissant
deux heures les membres devaient donner
un voleur pour
alors très rapidement commentaire
général sur ce débat chantal on a dit
beaucoup que legault avait été très
agressif avait remporté des points si
vous faisiez une joute oratoire à
l'université c'est sûr qu'ils auraient
été le grand gagnant de la soirée de
façon générale la regardant le portrait
de la campagne qui était celui quand
même le utah 2 philippe couillard qui a
le vent dans le dos si monsieur poulat
autant bordeaux a pris ce débat lors
qu'il l'avait il ya une semaine dans ce
que les débats n'ont pas d'importance
parce que ça a été très dur pour le ch
et des procès soient wiki qui a frappé
qui a reçu à peu près tous les coups
possibles ben il est en avance dans les
sondages donc on s'est tourné beaucoup
vers lui pour l'attaqué et en même temps
il trébuche et même un peu par lui-même
en sur la langue lost c'est un piège là
mais il est tombé dessus par lui-même et
était étendu le par françoise david mais
en même temps il y avait clairement leur
manque de réflexe la cote du côté de
philippe couillard et je suis d'accord
avec chantal candy wifi et françois de
quoi gagner le dépôt peut-être que
françoise david devient performer mais
en même temps les deux seuls qui ont une
chance actuellement de former le
gouvernement c'est philippe couillard et
pauline marois fallait les comparer
entre eux je donc faut donner l'avantagé
à pauline marois dans ce débat là parce
que c'est elle et lui qui vont à toutes
fins capables qui était manifestement
chantal beaucoup plus à l'aise madame
marois hier moi j'ai trouvé que le site
physique le fait d'être assise par
exemple avantage et pas seulement madame
marois mais aussi madame david les deux
valeurs plus confortable c'est quelque
chose que les faiseurs d'image des
parties devraient garder en tête ça se
peut que ce soit plus confortable pour
des femmes de faire des débats à six a
enlevé de l'autoritaire monsieur clients
au niveau de l'apparence mais au-delà de
ça madame marois valeurs plus au dessus
de ses affaires et ce qui me semble
important je suis le sait c'est presque
anecdotique et ça rien à voir avec les
points qu'on compte mais il m'a semblé
que l'image que dégage est moins énervé
plus sereine et est susceptible de faire
que les gens étaient plus content de
l'avoir dans leur salon que la semaine
précédente et je pense que ça c'est
important dans une campagne vous avez
tout à fait raison c'est absolument pas
anecdotique comment elle se présente on
élire après tout une première nuit sous
un premier ministre
on a beaucoup vu des parts dans cette
campagne rania peur du référendum sont
motivés beaucoup de gens voter la peur
de la charte ou le goût de la charte là
on est dans les tic quel genre de fin de
campagne on va avoir un chantage
moi j'ai l'impression que le groupe
d'électeurs qui va déterminer les unes
terminaux étant majoritaire péquiste
libéral c'est un groupe d'électeurs
flatteur qui finalement tu rends compte
autant les sondages que les gars c'est
pour ça que j'ai comme l'intuition que
si dans une semaine on a des sondages
qui montrent que le pq a de nouveau le
vent dans les voiles on pourrait revoir
un mouvement vers les libéraux parce
qu'on les voit se promener ses électeurs
depuis le début de la campagne et le
débat est là il s'adressait finalement
un très petit frange d'électeurs mais
ils sont très fluides ils peuvent aussi
bien aller se réfugier chez québec
solidaire chez la caq décider qui
ressortent de leurs parce qu'ils savent
pas ce que l'épouvantail déteste le plus
les familles électeurs de la cac alec
qu'on a dit qu'ils étaient revenus aux
libéraux dans une grande proportion ceux
là peuvent réfléchir là pour les
pongistes de cette montre satisfait de
la performance de françois legault en
même temps est-ce qu'ils vont croire une
marois qui indique qu'elles ne feront
pas de référendum tant que les québécois
ne veulent pas est ce qu'ils sont c'est
complètement disparu parce qu'elle à
l'arrivée de pia kjaersgaard avait quand
même suscité dans la campagne car elle
un changement extrêmement important et
je suis pas certain nous on aime
beaucoup la nouveauté et les
journalistes dont s'occupe du bruit
toutes les pistes nouvelles à chaque
jour mais ce qu'une nouvelle que dix
plus importantes que celles de jusqu'à
présent peut-être pas nécessairement
dans le temps pour beaucoup de lecteurs
est encore présent ça va du
tranquillement disparaître on va penser
à autre chose mais de leur dit que les
faits complètement perdus lors du
référendum et que l'on passe à autre
chose je pense qu'il reste encore
beaucoup de sueur dans le débat on va
voir pour les prochains jours le mais je
pense qu'il en reste encore je me
souviens moi que quand j'ai couvert la
dernière campagne fédérale à l'extérieur
du québec stephen harper passé son temps
parlé de la nécessité d'un gouvernement
stable en clair majoritaire et les
journalistes qu'on est tous passés à
autre chose après une journée et demie
en disant c'est très répétitif mais sur
le terrain le message qu'ont entendu
dans la bouche des électeurs qui parlait
de l'élection c'était ça et tu les
regardes le tout ce qu'on disait tous
les jours les gens qui peut pas les
aurélie le cil plus l'historiette du
jour c'était pas du tout sur les grandes
villes donc on fait une campagne à la
fois autrement dit monsieur couillard
risque de reparler au temps du
référendum madame marois de la charte
par exemple et d'autres une l'éthique de
l'e2c vraiment depuis quelques jours sur
ce thème là qui avait été un peu plus
payant pour elle dans le passé donc on
est revenu à ça parce que la charte je
l'entend pas beaucoup même si on a
essayé de faire c'est pour l'instant pas
un enjeu qui accroche pense que
l'éthique et l'intégrité beaucoup plus
accrochée depuis une semaine j'ai fait
beaucoup plus mal ou libéraux d'ailleurs
que la question de la charge donc je
pense qu'elle est encore sur ce thème
lambeaux moins pour quelques jours le
certainement chantal le mot de la fin
une fin de campagne vous le dit on verra
qu'un héros des sondages ont dit
peut-être jeudi vendredi c'est bon on
verra mais totalement imprévisible
imprévisible mais on va voir aussi un
petit peu où s'en vont les sondages
quand on va voir comment les partis font
campagne parce que la dernière ce même
canton va bien on va chez le voisin
essayer de prendre les xaré quand on
voit mal en défense qu'on trouve faible
avec les teams erreurs des chefs des
prochains jours vont être aussi parlants
que les sondages qui vont arriver jeudi
ou un brevet justement merci chantal
hébert alec castonguay on va présenter